del más grande y más intacto bosque en el mundo,
el bosque boreal de Canadá.
Se expande justo a través del norte de Canadá, en Labrador,
Es el hogar de la más grande manada salvaje sobreviviente de caribú
en el mundo, la manada de caribú del río George,
alcanzando aproximadamente 400,000 animales.
Desafortunadamente, cuando estuve allí no pude localizar a ninguno,
mas están los cuernos como prueba.
A través de toda la zona boreal, somos afortunados de esta
increíble abundancia de pantanos.
Los pantanos a nivel mundial son uno de los principales ecosistemas en peligro.
Ellos son ecosistemas absolutamente cruciales,
ellos limpian el aire, el agua,
ellos secuestran grandes cantidades de gases de efecto invernadero,
y son hogar de una enorme diversidad de especies.
En la zona boreal, ellos son además la morada donde
casi 50 por ciento de las 800 especies de aves
ubicadas en América del Norte migran al norte para reproducir y criar a sus vástagos.
En Ontario, la zona boreal avanza del sur
a la orilla norte del Lago Superior.
Y estos bosques boreales increíblemente hermosos
fueron la inspiración para algo del más famoso arte
en la historia de Canadá, el Grupo de los Siete fueron muy inspirados
por estos paisajes,
y así la zona boreal no es sólo en efecto una parte clave de nuestro
patrimonio natural,
sino también una parte importante de nuestro patrimonio cultural.
En Manitoba, esta es una imagen del lado este del Lago Winnipeg,
y este es el hogar del recientemente designado
sitio del Patrimonio Cultural de la UNESCO.
En Saskatchewan, como a través de toda la zona boreal,
paraje de algunos de nuestros ríos más famosos,
y de una increíble red de ríos y lagos
que cada niño en edad escolar aprende al respecto,
el Peace, el Athabasca, el Churchill aquí, el Mackenzie,
y estas redes fueron las rutas históricas
para el viajero y el leñador,
los primeros exploradores no aborígenes del norte de Canadá
que, recibiendo de gente de las Naciones Originarias de Canadá
usaron canoas y remaron para explorar
una ruta comercial, un Pasaje del Noroeste para el comercio de pieles.
En el norte, la zona boreal es bordeada por la tundra,
y justo bajo aquella, en Yukón,
Tenemos este increíble valle, el Valle Tombstone.
y el Valle Tombstone es el hogar de la manada de caribues Porcupine.
Bueno, Uds. probablemente han oído acerca de la manada de caribues Porcupine.
en el contexto de su área de reproducción
en el Refugio Nacional de Vida Silvestre del Ártico
Bien, el área de invernada es también crítica
y además no esta protegida,
y es potencialmente, podría ser potencialmente, explotada
por derechos de explotación minera y de gas.
El borde oeste de la zona boreal en la Columbia Británica,
está marcado por la Cordillera de la Costa,
y por el otro lado de estas montañas
está el más grande bosque pluvial templado restante en el mundo,
el bosque pluvial del Gran Oso,
y discutiremos esto en breves minutos con un poco más de detalle.
A través de toda la zona boreal, está el hogar de un inmenso
e increíble hábitat de personas indígenas,
y una rica y variada cultura.
y creo que una de las razones por las cuales
tantos de estos grupos han retenido su vínculo con el pasado,
conocen sus lenguas nativas,
las canciones, las danzas, las tradiciones,
Creo en parte la razón es debido a el alejamiento,
el lapso y la tierra salvaje
de ésta casi 95 por ciento del ecosistema intacto.
Y creo particularmente ahora,
mientras nos vemos en un tiempo de crisis medioambiental,
podemos aprender tanto de estas personas
quienes han vivido tan sustentable en este ecosistema
por más de 10,000 años.
En el corazón de este ecosistema está la misma antítesis
de todos estos valores los cuales hemos estado hablando acerca de,
y creo que estos son algunos de los valores fundamentales
los cuales nos hacen sentir orgullosos de ser canadienses.
Estas son las arenas de alquitrán de Alberta.
las reservas de petróleo más grandes del planeta
aparte de Arabia Saudita.
Atrapadas debajo del bosque boreal
y los pantanos del norte de Alberta,
están estas vastas reservas de este pegajoso, betún tipo alquitrán.
Y la explotación minera y el aprovechamiento de esto,
está creando devastación a una escala que el planeta jamás había visto antes.
Quiero intentar transmitir algún tipo de sentido respecto al tamaño de esto.
Si Uds. miran aquel camión de allá,
es el camión más grande de su tipo en el planeta.
Es un camión basculante de 360 toneladas métricas de capacidad
y sus dimensiones son 14 metros de largo
por 11 metros de ancho y 8 metros de alto.
Si me ubico al lado de aquel camión,
mi cabeza llega más o menos a la base
de la parte amarilla de ese tapacubo.
Dentro de las dimensiones de aquel camión,
podría construirse muy fácilmente una casa de dos pisos de 280 metros cuadrados
con toda facilidad. Hice las matemáticas.
Entonces, en vez de pensar en aquel como un camión,
piensen en aquel como una casa de 280 metros cuadrados.
Esa no es una casa de mal tamaño.
Y alineen aquellos camiones/casas una y otra vez
a través de allí desde la base
todo el recorrido hasta la parte superior.
Y luego, piensen en cuán grande es la muy pequeña sección de una mina.
Bueno, Uds. pueden aplicar ese mismo tipo de razonamiento
también aquí.
Bueno, aquí Uds. ven–desde luego, a medida que Uds. se alejan más,
estos camiones se convierten en un píxel.
Nuevamente, imaginen todos ellos una y otra vez acá allá.
¿Cuán grande es esta porción de una mina?
Aquella sería un área metropolitana vasta e inmensa,
probablemente, mucho más grande que la Ciudad de Victoria.
Y esta es sólo una dentro de un número de minas,
10 minas hasta ahora.
Esta es una parte de un complejo minero,
y existen alrededor de otros 40 o 50 en proceso de aprobación.
A ninguna mina de arenas de alquitrán núnca le ha sido en realidad denegada la aprobación,
pués es esencialmente un simple sellado.
El otro método de extracción es el denominado in situ.
y aquí, cantidades masivas de agua
son sobrecalentadas y bombeadas a través del suelo,
por medio de estas vastas redes de tuberías,
líneas sísmicas, senderos de perforación, estaciones de compresores.
Y aún cuando esto parezca no del todo tan repugnante
como las minas, es aún más dañino de alguna forma.
Impacta y fragmenta una gran parte de la naturaleza,
donde existe una disminución de 90 por ciento de las especies importantes,
como el caribú del bosque y los osos pardos,
y ello consume aun más energía, más agua,
y produce por lo menos tanto gas de efecto invernadero.
Por lo tanto, estas explotaciones in situ son por lo menos tan
dañinas desde el punto de vista ecológico como las minas.
El petróleo producido por cualquiera de ambos métodos
genera más emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero que cualquier otro petróleo.
Esta es una de las razones por las cuales es denominado
el petróleo más sucio del mundo.
Es además, una de las razones por las que es
la única fuente de carbono más grande y de mayor
crecimiento en Canadá,
y es también la razón por la que ahora Canadá es el número tres
en términos de generación de carbono por persona.
Los relaves son los depósitos tóxicos más grandes del planeta.
Las arenas aceitosas—o mejor debiera decir, arenas de alquitrán—
“arenas aceitosas” es un término creado por Relaciones Públicas
a fin de que las compañías petroleras no estuviesen intentando promover
algo que sonase como una substancia tipo alquitrán pegajoso
el cual es el petróleo más sucio del mundo.
Por lo tanto, decidieron denominarlo arenas aceitosas.
Las arenas de alquitrán consumen más agua que ningún otro proceso petrolífero,
de 480 a 800 litros de agua son tomados, contaminados
y posteriormente devueltos a los relaves,
los depósitos de tóxicos más grandes del planeta.
SemCrude, sólo una de las licencias,
en sólo uno de sus relaves,
vacía 230,000 toneladas métricas de mugre tóxica cada día.
Ello está creando los más grandes depósitos tóxicos
en la historia del planeta.
Hasta el momento, ésta es suficiente toxina
para cubrir la cara del Lago Eerie con 30 centímetros de profundidad.
Y los relaves oscilan en tamaño hasta 3,600 hectáreas.
Aquello equivale a dos tercios del tamaño completo de la isla de Manhattan.
Eso es como desde Wall Street en el borde sur de Manhattan.
hasta quizás la calle 120.
Así, esto es absolutamente —
esto es uno de los más grandes relaves.
Esto podría ser, ¿qué? No lo sé, la mitad del tamaño de Manhattan.
Y Uds. puede apreciar en el contexto,
es sólo una sección relativamente pequeña
de uno de los 10 complejos mineros y otros 40 a 50
en vías de ser aprobados pronto.
Y por supuesto, estos relaves—
bueno, Uds. no pueden apreciar muchos estanques desde el espacio exterior
y Uds. pueden ver estos, así que quizá debiéramos dejar de llamarles estanques—
estos páramos tóxicos robustos son construídos
libremente y sobre los bancos del río Athabasca.
Y el río Athabasca drena río abajo
a una serie de comunidades aborígenes.
En el Fuerte Chippewa, las 800 personas ahí,
están encontrando toxinas en la cadena alimenticia,
esto ha sido comprobado científicamente.
Las toxinas de las arenas de alquitrán, están en la cadena alimenticia,
y esto está provocando tasas de cáncer
hasta 10 veces superiores de lo que ocurre en el resto de Canadá,
A pesar de ello, la gente tiene que vivir,
tiene que comer este alimento a fin de sobrevivir.
El precio increíblemente alto
de enviar alimentos por carga aérea a estas remotas comunidades de aborígenes del norte
y la alta tasa de desempleo,
convierten esto en una necesidad absoluta por sobrevivir.
Y no hace muchos años, un hombre de las Naciones Originarias de Canadá me prestó un bote.
y dijo, “Cuando usted salga del río,
bajo ninguna circunstancia coma pescado.
Es cancerígeno.”
A pesar de ello, en el porche delantero de la cabaña del hombre,
vi cuatro pescados. Él tenía que alimentar a su familia para sobrevivir.
Y como padre, no puedo imaginar lo que aquello provoca en el alma de aquel hombre.
Y eso es lo que nosotros estamos haciendo.
El bosque boreal es además
quizás nuestra mejor defensa contra el calentamiento global y el cambio climático.
El bosque boreal secuestra más carbono
que ningún otro ecosistema terrestre.
Y esto es absolutamente clave.
Entonces, lo que estamos haciendo es,
estamos tomando el más concentrado sumidero de gases de invernadero,
dos veces más gases de invernadero son secuestrados en
el bosque boreal por hectárea que en los bosques pluviales tropicales.
Y lo que estamos haciendo es destruir
este sumidero de carbono, convirtiéndolo en una bomba de carbono.
Y lo estamos reemplazando por el más grande
proyecto industrial en la historia del mundo,
el cual está produciendo el petróleo con mayor emisión de gases de
efecto invernadero con alto carbono en el mundo.
Y estamos haciendo esto sobre la segunda más grande
reserva de petróleo en el planeta
Esta es una de las razones por las cuales Canadá,
en un principio héroe del cambio climático—
Fuimos uno de los primeros signatarios del Protocolo de Kioto.
Ahora, somos el país que tiene cabilderos de tiempo completo
en la Unión Europea y Washington, D.C.
intimidando con guerras comerciales cuando estos países
hablan sobre el querer traer legislación positiva
para limitar la importación de combustible de alto carbono,
de emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero, o cualquiera similar,
en conferencias internacionales,
sin importar si ellas son en Copenhague o Cancún,
las conferencias internacionales sobre cambio climático,
somos el país que consigue el premio dinosaurio
cada día siendo el mayor obstáculo
para progresar en este problema.
Sólo 113 km río abajo,
está la desembocadura de agua dulce más grande del mundo,
la desembocadura Peace-Athabasca,
la única en la unión de todas las cuatro rutas de vuelo migratorias.
Este es un pantano globalmente significativo,
quizá el más extenso del planeta.
Increíble hábitat para la mitad de las especies de aves,
las cuales Uds. encuentran en América del Norte, migran aquí.
Y también el último refugio para la más grande manada de búfalo,
y además, por supuesto, el hábitat crucial para una variedad completa de otras especies.
Asimismo, está siendo amenazado por la enorme cantidad
de agua que es extraída del Athabasca,
el cual alimenta estos pantanos,
y también la increíble carga tóxica
de los más grandes depósitos de tóxicos sin pautar del planeta,
los cuales se están colando hacia la cadena alimenticia
para todas las especies río abajo.
Así, tan perjudicial como todo ello es, las cosas se volverán
mucho peores, mucho, mucho peores.
Esta es la infraestructura como la vemos actualmente.
Esto es lo que está planificado para 2015.
Y Uds. pueden apreciar aquí el Oleoducto Keystone,
el cual llevaría arenas de alquitrán crudo hasta el Golfo de México,
perforando una tubería a través del centro,
el centro agrícola de Norteamérica, de los Estados Unidos,
y asegurando el contrato con el combustible más sucio del mundo,
para consumo de los Estados Unidos,
y promoviendo un enorme impedimento
para una futura energía limpia y sustentable para Estados Unidos.
Aquí Uds. ven la ruta hacia el Valle Mackenzie.
Ésta colocaría una tubería para llevar gas natural
desde el Mar de Beaufort a través del centro
de la tercera cuenca hídrica más grande en el mundo,
y la única que permanece 95 por ciento intacta.
Y construyendo una tubería con una autopista industrial
cambiaría para siempre esta increíble tierra salvaje,
la cual es una verdadera rareza en el planeta hoy en día.
Así, el bosque pluvial del Gran Oso está justo sobre
la colina de allá, dentro de unos cuantos kilómetros vamos desde estos
bosques boreales secos con árboles de 100 años de edad,
quizá 25 centímetros de ancho,
y pronto estamos en el bosque pluvial costero templado,
empapada de lluvia, con árboles de 1,000 años de edad,
6 metros de ancho, un ecosistema completamente diferente.
El bosque pluvial del Gran Oso es generalmente considerado
ser el mayor ecosistema de bosque pluvial costero templado
en el mundo.
Uno de los de mayores densidades,
una de las especias más icónicas y amenazadas del planeta,
y aun así, existe una propuesta, por supuesto, para construir una tubería
para llevar enormes buques petroleros, 10 veces el tamaño del Exxon Valdez,
a través de una de las aguas más dificultosas de navegar en el mundo,
donde sólo hace unos pocos años,
un transbordador de la Columbia Británica encalló.
Cuando uno de estos buques alquitraneros,
llevando el petróleo más sucio, 10 veces tanto como el Exxon Valdez,
casualmente golpee una roca y se hunda,
vamos a tener uno de los peores desastres ecológicos
que el planeta jamás haya presenciado.
Y aquí tenemos el plan en detalle para el 2030.
Lo que ellos están proponiendo es un incremento de casi cuatro veces en la producción,
y aquello industrializaría un área del tamaño de Florida.
De hacer esto, estaremos removiendo
una gran parte de nuestro más extenso sumidero de carbono
y reemplazándolo por el petróleo de más alta emisión de gases de
invernadero en el futuro.
El mundo no requiere ninguna mina de alquitrán más.
El mundo no necesita más tuberías
para unir nuestra adicción a los combustibles fósiles.
Y el mundo ciertamente no necesita
los depósitos de tóxicos más grandes para acrecentar y multiplicar
y más aún amenazar a las comunidades río abajo.
Y encaremoslo, todos nosotros vivimos río abajo,
en una era de calentamiento global y cambio climático.
Lo que necesitamos es actuar
para asegurar que Canadá respete
las enormes cantidades de agua dulce
que poseemos en este país.
Necesitamos asegurar que estos pantanos y bosques
los cuales constituyen nuestra mejor y más grandiosa y crucial
defensa contra el calentamiento global sean protegidos,
y que no estemos liberando aquella bomba de carbono hacia la atmósfera.
Y requerimos reunirnos todos juntos
y decirle no a las arenas de alquitrán.
Y podemos hacer esto. Existe una enorme red
alrededor de todo el mundo luchando por detener este proyecto.
Y creo simplemente que esto no es
algo que deba ser decidido sólo en Canadá.
Todos en este salón, cada uno a lo ancho de Canadá,
cada uno de los que está escuchando esta presentación tiene un rol que desempeñar
y, creo, una responsabilidad.
Porque lo que hagamos aquí,
va a cambiar nuestra historia,
va a influir en nuestra posibilidad de sobrevivir,
para que nuestros hijos sobrevivan,
y tengan un futuro próspero.
Tenemos un increíble obsequio en la zona boreal,
una oportunidad increíble para preservar
nuestra mejor defensa contra el calentamiento global,
mas podríamos dejar aquello escaparse.
Las arenas de alquitrán podrían amenazar
no sólo a una gran parte de la zona boreal.
Compromete la vida y la salud
de algunas de nuestras más desamparadas y vulnerables gente,
las comunidades Aborígenes, las cuales tienen demasiado que enseñarnos.
Podría destruir la desembocadura del Athabasca,
la más grande y posiblemente más grandiosa desembocadura de agua dulce del planeta.
Podría destruir el bosque pluvial del Gran Oso,
el más grande bosque pluvial templado del mundo,
y podría tener enormes impactos,
en el futuro de la zona central agrícola de Norteamérica,
Espero que todos ustedes tengan la voluntad, si se han conmovido con esta presentación,
de unirse a la creciente comunidad internacional,
para conseguir que Canadá se acerque a sus responsabilidades,
para conseguir que Canadá vuelva a ser un defensor del cambio climático,
en lugar de ser un villano del cambio climático,
y diga no a las arenas de alquitrán,
y sí a una futura energía limpia para todos.
Muchísimas gracias.
[Aplausos]